Jennifer any advice to authors who are
hoping to turn their books into movies
yeah I have actually quite a few
thoughts on that one of my main thoughts
is that figuring out what is the
appropriate way to tell your book into a
story so sometimes it's going to be more
appropriate for film and as mentioned if
your book is not like a pretty sweeping
kind of tentpole sort of movie you're
gonna have a hard time selling that to a
major movie studio right now based on
the types of material they're actually
making they're not really doing many men
range films anymore the can flip side of
that is if it could be made for a very
good price micro budget or a low budget
then you're gonna have probably some
options for film but I think TV is
really worth considering now and how it
would slot in in terms of how to
position it for that and again you know
getting a good film agent film TV agent
to represent the rights is really
important and like I said I think having
a vision for what it's gonna be
is it like Star Wars is it like you know
something that's on TV stranger things
was a huge hit on Netflix is it
something like that like what is the way
that you position the material could
help with finding the right audience for
it and figuring out what it looks like
it's kind of the same as pitching it to
a publishing house like what is your
book like what kind of film will it make
so you have your literary agent but then
you're also looking for a film and
television yeah so that's a whole
process so I actually think I have and I
think my four agents actually that
represent me right now and so um they
did all come through my book agent so
getting so if you have a book agent they
should be able to help you especially if
you've interests which in my case I did
I'd interest from producers so they
should be able to help set you up with a
film and TV agent and so I am at ICM
with Josie Freedman who is amazing and
who I had done deals with and seeing her
represent ICM as one of the best book
departments in the business they were
presenting a lot of huge authors so I'm
thrilled to be with her and to be
represented by them and so she handles
all the film TV aspect because it's all
highly specialized my book agent again
that's specialized to what she does and
then the other agents I work with are
Curtis Brown who represent
UK writes in my foreign translation
rights so we've actually sold China
Russia
I believe so they kind of handled that
and that's also highly specialized so
yes getting set up with the right people
and I have some insider knowledge of
Hollywood but if you don't it is a very
tricky business in town to figure out to
know who's real who's not what's a good
fit what's not so you really do need a
good representative and I believe that
strongly another option would be an
entertainment attorney who can often
help do deals and advise you in in so in
a-1 entertainment attorney versus
several agents well the agents all do
different things so an entertainment
attorney would be in place of having a
film or TV agent or manager you know you
basically need someone who can help you
do the deals and you know represent the
material and potentially even take it
out on submission or take it to the
right people because it's like the
gatekeeper that gets you in the door
Hollywood you're gonna have a really
tough time getting much done if you
don't have someone that's an insider who
knows the world because it's a highly
specialized business so even if you have
a great attorney that's they've been
with your family for years but they have
no connections inside then I mean
someone like that might be able to
review a contract for you but again like
what it goes in these deals is specific
so it's a specialized area of law so if
they don't really know what is the
industry standards and what are the
norms it might be hard for them I mean
they could probably advise you on you
know basic contract stuff but yeah I
think it's really important to have
someone that they do these kind of deals
and they understand them and I always
advise everyone like please have
representation before you sign anything
and that could be an attorney it could
be the author skilled but somebody needs
to look at your contracts because you
can get to a lot of trouble if you sign
you know a bad deal and a lot of
creative people do sometimes get taken
advantage of or do sometimes sign deals
that aren't in their best interest and
that doesn't just apply to writers flies
all across the business so I'm a big
believer in having good people on your
team that can advise you the nice thing
about agents is that they take a
percentage so you're not paying that
right off the bat so they're working
kind of I want to say it's for free but
it's like you're not paying anyone
everyone gets paid at the same time and
a good representative should earn their
percentage because they should get you a
better deal an attorney you're usually
going to be paying them more hourly so
you might be going out of pocket
you